[Musique]
24 mai 2006 je viens de découvrir le jeu
world of warcraft
apparemment il ya des millions de
joueurs qui naviguent dans l'univers du
jeu par des heures par semaine à jouer
parfois même pendant des années je
comprends pas pourquoi ces jeunes
passent autant de temps avec des
inconnus au lieu d'être avec leurs amis
je me demande qu'est ce qu'ils trouvent
dans ce monde virtuel est ce qu'ils vont
chercher dans ses rapports sociaux est à
suivre
30 mai 2006 après une semaine de jeu je
vous avoue que je suis tanné de voir des
inconnus midi pour combattre plusieurs
joueurs vont même denis gratuitement des
boeufs un genre de sorts pour la plupart
du temps je les connais même pas ce
genre de comportement m'intrigue
beaucoup parce qu'au départ je croyais
que les joueurs étaient dans un mode
compétition de vie qu'ils ne cherchaient
qu'à être les meilleurs quand même pris
du mauvais goût
fait octobre 2008
je vais passer une vingtaine de la tenue
d'un chat on explique que c'est une
initiation pour les kings ou on perd du
temps à faire des niaiseries au lieu de
jouer
j'imagine que c'est pour souder les
liens dans la guilde lui comprendre
aujourd'hui j'entre dans une guilde à
suivre 29 octobre 2008
depuis moment pris dans la guilde tout
le monde m'aide on donne de l'équipement
mais vit dans des quêtes on m'aide à
progresser
on m'invite même un bal masqué pour
l'halloween 31 octobre 2008
j'ai sorti mon équipement le plus
improbable pour faire rire les autres
en communiquant par le chat vocal j'ai
l'impression d'être à côté de développer
des liens d'amitié
[Musique]
ce 9 mars 2009 après avoir passé autant
de temps avec les joueurs de ma guilde
être heureuse de nos réussites déçu
d'avoir échoué un donjon et même à m
fâché contre les joueurs désagréable je
comprends que ce moment n'est pas
virtuel est bien réelle
j'ai découvert que le jeu est comme une
société il continuation de ce que nous
sommes
[Musique]
30 janvier 2015 je suis mon bon enfant
professeur en communication sociale et
publique à l'uqam et je fais des
recherches sur la communication la
socialisation et les représentations
dans les jeux vidéo bonjour moon
bonjour vous êtes à montréal vous nous
parlez de montréal et vous rouler de
manière autonome sur la scène du tedx
cannes alors mode quel est ce fameux
homo ludens dont vous nous parlez est en
fait l'aumône idem c'est l'humain qui
jouent et donc c'est celui qui va jouer
à des jeux vidéo à des jeux de sorte à
des jeux de rôle d avec les enfants même
avec le chien comprendre avec le jeu
c'est comme un engrenage et en fait dans
un engrenage pour qu'il fonctionne il
faut qu'il est justement une espace de
jeu et donc pour mieux pas cet espace de
jeu long l'engrenage coince la même
chose avec le jeu est en fait il faut
des règles plus au sein des règles un
espace de jeux espace de liberté pour
les joueurs qui puissent poser des choix
et donc à ce moment à l'autre
explications du jeune et donc qu'est ce
que le monde moderne mais c'est celui
qui s'approprient cet espace de jeu cet
espace de liberté dans sa vie alors dans
les entreprises dont le sport dont
l'armée voir dans l'éducation il ya de
plus en plus de domaines qui utilise les
principes du jeu vidéo
pour quelles raisons d'après vous est
d'abord un déclaré mme décarie freestyle
principal du jeu la motivation c'est
motivant de jouer c'est stimulant c'est
plaisant et donc c'est un lieu parfait
pour d'apprentissage puisqu'on est
motivé on est motivés a aussi à faire
des actions ont fait faire des choses
aux gens et donc ils ont pas
nécessairement prendre pleine conscience
de ce qu'ils sont en train de faire
parce que tu as inscrit dans leur
comportement on leur fait faire des
actions et ainsi la prem est donc dans
nos copies si les jeux pourraient des
lieux de simulation ça fait aussi des
lieux très fictif récréatif eric même et
donc de capter la formation et c'est
aussi un moyen idéal pour des
apprentissages
alors en quoi
les mécaniques du jeu vidéo les
mécaniques de progression de récompenses
voire même de dépendances sont-elles
symptomatique d'après vous de notre
époque
si on reprend la réponse précédente on
voit que le jeu c'est un lieu qui motive
à faire des actions dans un contexte les
uns et donc on a du plaisir à jouer donc
dans la set notre société de plaisir le
jusqu'à ce que tu as fait parfaitement
par ailleurs dans le jeu il ya beaucoup
de récompenses et donc c'est très
gratifiant de jouer on s'est très
rapidement quelles actions on le fait on
bonnes ou mauvaises et les objectifs
sont très claires donc on fait une bonne
action une récompense donc dangereux
monde qui est parfois peu en vue où on
connaît pas nécessairement les effets
nos actions le jeu fait par être reçue
au camp dans ce sens là l'autre élément
de réponse est intéressant c'est la
culture participative dans laquelle on
vit depuis qu'ils ont annoncé avec
l'explosion du web 2.0 au début des
années 2000 on veut plus seulement être
des spectateurs on va être des
spectateurs et donc le joueur participe
est acteur et donc en ce sens seul je
réponds aussi passer bien à notre époque
alors dans le domaine du jeu on parle de
gainer fication ludification on parle
aussi de quantification de soi
finalement ça s'apparente un petit peu
au tracking comportementale
qu'en pensez vous oui c'est la
quantification soit c'est une
quantification des actions et comme je
l'expliquais tantôt les jeux c'est un
espace de liberté en marge qu'on l'est
de créativité aux joueurs donc la simple
accumulation de quoi il peut pas être
considéré comme du jeu donc on parle
plutôt de grigny fication en anglais ou
de l'identification
c'est pas vraiment du jury donc ça
devient des petites stratégies et
performante pour changer les
comportements parce qu'il ya des
récompenses très clair vous fait
l'action quand on veut vous fassiez on
vous donne un point où il est entre
terol et donc elles savent ne contient
ni un certain comportement n'est faut
poser des questions c'est quels sont les
objectifs que sont les visées qui énonce
et viser là et quel genre de
comportement
normaliser avec ses stratégies de
l'unification en arrière c'est vraiment
l'idée de l'humain est ce qu on a l'idée
d'un joueur et sa propre ni son espace
de liberté qui est libre pour sa vie ou
au contraire c'est quelqu'un qu'on veut
venir concours et donc on veut venir
influencer le comportement donc alors ce
sera ainsi l'offre que je regardais en
fait que le jeu n'est pas toujours si le
français pourrait bien le croire
et qu'en est il de la collecte en fait
des données fournies par l'utilisateur
quid de la protection de la vie privée
mais c'est une excellente question
justement qui fait lien avec le côté pas
toujours inoffensif du jeu parfois
utilisé le jeu pour aller collecter des
données personnelles par exemple les
concours on peut demander des
informations privées sur les gens ou
bien on va essayer d'utiliser des
stratégies de l'édification pour garder
connecter pour essayer d'aller capter le
maximum de données et donc de ce côté là
mais ça peut être dangereux et dont faut
rester vigilant par ailleurs dans le
concept du jeu vidéo on se rend compte
c'est que ya une banalisation de la
surveillance les joueurs sont habitués à
savoir qui joue quand quel moment
qu'elle jouait terrain est donc cette
banalisation de la surveillance va être
transférée à l'extérieur du contexte du
jeu et on m'en donne ni on a plus assez
le souci de cette captation massive de
données
les solutions qui sont à mettre de
l'avant ses dames à une législation pour
unir lige ferry cette captation de
données personnelles puis l'utilisation
qui va être faite de cette année là il
faut les protéger
et alors on a l'impression que le monde
du jeu vidéo c'est quand même le monde
du virtuel et qu'on agit à travers d'
avatar est là aussi quid de la
transposition dans le monde réel
en fait le virtuel est ce que ça veut
dire 2.8 ma logique c'est ce n'était en
puissance qui n'a pas lieu
et en fait car je suis dans un jeu vidéo
ça il sait très très actuelle il ya des
effets très complexe et donc par exemple
les émotions puis je suis fâché en
joueurs je suis le réel
entaché ces photos virtuelles et donc
tous mais les aztèques ou bien les
apprentissages comment on va faire
rouler toutes les expériences sont très
réels comme la socialisation et donc
donc moi dans mes études que je me suis
rendu compte que les joueurs même s'ils
se sont jamais vus en face à face vont
parler de leurs amis et donc développe
des amis près d elle même certaines ont
rencontré leurs amoureux en ligne et
donc en ce sens cela c'est tout à fait
réelle aussi réelle que moi dans ce
robot présentement et leur mode comment
vous voyez-vous le jeu vidéo dans dix
ans mais sept mois ça va faire quinze
ans que je travaille sur le jeu et j'ai
vraiment vu une évolution c'est à dire
ya vraiment une croissance du jeu dans
notre société c'est pas par exemple par
une acceptabilité sociale de plus en
plus acceptée de plus en plus de joueurs
aussi
et donc on a de moins en moins de
préjugés négatifs par rapport au jeu le
langage le dico si on s'habitue beaucoup
on le voit qu'il utilisait beaucoup en
marketing et donc on comprend rapidement
qu'on entend de nuit avec une système de
points et donc dans cette donnée là on
va voir le jeu ici de plus en plus
présent du côté de l'industrie du jeu
vidéo on sait qu'on a des compagnies
majeures en jeu vidéo mais aussi toutes
sortes de petites compagnies
indépendantes créé des jeux tout à fait
intéressant et ce coup là qui va
chercher toutes sortes de joueurs avec
toutes sortes de thématiques et donc le
jeu vidéo est appelé à croître
certainement dans les prochaines années
et si on regarde vraiment dans dix ans
il faut voir la réalité virtuelle
arriver et donc ils l'ont mordu des
besoins en eau à un casque de réalité
sur la traite et peut-être même un robot
qui sait on verra merci merci beaucoup
mode votre intervention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]